associated press reporter joe fetterman
is in the capital of ukraine joe you've
been there for nearly a week now
does tonight feel different more ominous
absolutely uh there's a sense almost
that the walls are closing in on this
city just a few moments ago we heard
four loud explosions it came a couple of
hours after a missile strike on a tv
antenna
inside the city that's one of the first
russian attacks on locations in the city
the city itself central key very tense
today not only are the streets empty
which has been the case for several days
but heavy security presence lots of
checkpoints as we try to move around so
there's really a sense of dread and then
in addition to that you have this
military convoy just on the outskirts of
town about 15 miles outside of the city
so really a sense of dread as the
attacks are coming in from all
directions and joe i know russia warned
people in kyiv to leave their homes if
they're anywhere near communication and
military facilities but do you have a
sense of what is being hit
yes this missile strike struck an
antenna used by the ukrainian national
television station
and that antenna serves other tv
stations and it disrupted transmissions
so russia apparently thinks of this uh
as a strategic asset they want to
disrupt communications they probably
want to send a message this is a very
symbolic target and they're going to
continue to go after sites like that but
it's important to note that these
strikes are not always accurate and
russia has also been hitting civilian
targets right nearby this antenna for
example
ukraine's national holocaust memorial
also struck
president zielinski has said he is
russia's number one target he's still in
kiev he did an interview from there
today what do we know about his
situation his safety tonight
we know very little uh they have been
very cagey very secretive about his
movements uh about troop movements about
the movements of the leaders uh but he
does manage to come out and make
statements and some of these statements
have been right outside of his offices
so he appears to be in the capitol as
you know he has rejected calls and
offers to leave to safer places so he is
sticking by his people all right joe
fetterman with the associated press in
kiev tonight thanks